[Music]
all right now the bar cops gonna come
and claim is dead yeah lot desert man
it's gonna make you pay for this we will
make them pay we'll be ready
my men have cleared the road to the
north you can campaign safe thank you
the revolution begins now sister the
water begins now brother was a hot rod
oh stop it
20 years of civil war there's nothing
simple about it adheres well-trained
teamed up kidnapped it doesn't matter
he took the gas to Russia today he did
that without its own this help got the
network in the manpower could you blame
it right unofficially no but this is
bigger than hi dear now we've got two
options
we will Moscow or we let Mother Russia
have a taste of her own medicine a
little visibility they died at the hands
of a Western Asset firstly let's cut to
the chase what do you suggest a business
trip unsanctioned hello miss your team
smoke coming in a surgeon
- ready
I can get you in that bedroom host
nation weapons for me give it to me
it's a hell of a view Nick and I was the
capital before Moscow the good old days
hmm I got two on the door more Alcatel
inside good spot parking here sucks
mr. butcher yellow shirt basta from the
embassy no guess another deal
hmm tempting you know how fast a butcher
gets us the idea or the gas attack goes
off well if that happens then we're all
[ __ ]
let's gear up get evil clock's ticking
this way what's the time for him hours
or less yeah best I could do on short
notice
split em all no flash bangs
nice job Nick holy cow hollow points 150
grain your favorite conceal it for now
but early at the warehouse ghost bring
the package on my way captain oh no you
want another stroke the butcher
okay deep enough for that sick bastard
sir you'll have your chance right now
Winnie the butcher life
we split up so they can't spend the
others and move it on the rear door
watch
goes on my signal before Nikolai trash
in the early
I brought back you think of everything
check your shots butcher gets us the
idea we need to breathe and until he
does today pain and suffering is not
ours but there's we give special thanks
to our new soldier strong soldier good
fortune there was a light yellow in the
table and if he is gone we deliver his
truth to those who are there be where
they are
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
because of you pizza pockets on the moon
Riverside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
step it up through the cafe Riverside
stop where are you
your home engine easily
cover them up
[Music]
[Music]
where was the chemicals of your [ __ ]
the Russian ass you can't hurt me you
piece of [ __ ]
but you captain oh you can do better
than that
you think I forgot your face sis are you
sergeant we need to break this boss I
got it
we're about to go where's the package
calling you now captain okay we've got a
Nikolai you get a package you come back
here
sergeant Eric Beckett is in the back
what is it
truth for a negotiation
perhaps the butcher will change where
are you taking us where are we going we
are going to talk to some men and then
we will go you're doing it you're
innocent people
like the man to know why we are here
Carl
you don't have to do this you in or out
I'm in sir good child
he's got no problems with hurting
children there are sergeant non shut up
this away from us captain
I can't do this excuse
no no we want the gas we're all these
things they will happen nothing here
will change that yeah rest assured I
wouldn't let me sergeant British along a
few doors unless you have no chance with
the gas I swear to you where's the DIA
Youngblood
you're too late to stop him go sergeant
save some [ __ ] Russians general Burke
I've already be dead
he's going after bark off the West go to
war go on kill me and you'll never get
what you're looking for I told you
everything sergeant do what you want
with me I let my family leave gosh is at
the correct theater security call it any
another drill will cruise it is yours
it'll get south of the city there is it
back off sigh state we're gonna kill him
start to world war gotta forget it first
covers Fox I'm timing compactify yet
visually McCarthy
Nnamani FCM the loss the keepers of
pasta ste Emma Cottard celli miss Nick's
dis the shortage in the city of booty by
checkpoint
for us what is there a difference
oh it's bloat what's the plan
shock and awe what they don't know
seconds
holy [ __ ] Nikolai stacked up back up
whilst they follow they won't
boss the hell are we doing it looks like
a mess with women and children I will /
if they were hostages you'll trade the
gloves off you get blood on your hands
Kyle I sell it works
where do we draw the line I saw you draw
the line wherever you need it soldier
under the day someone has to make the
enemy scared of the dark we get dirty
and the world stays clean that's the
mission now if you're having second
thoughts and I can do this on my own
[Music]
no sir not second thoughts good
now let's get here before he kills back
off
you
[Music]